hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the ftx crypto cup where we have a
very nice treat it is a magnus carlsen
versus yanni parnishes so the world
champion versus world championship
challenger
uh they will face each other for the
title of world champion in november in
dubai but for now
we have this very nice rapid game from
the ftx crypto cup magnus has the white
pieces
uh so let's see how the game went it's
uh it gets pretty crazy
uh right out of the opening so magnus
with the white pieces
opens with e4 nipple goes for the
sicilian defense
we have knife to c3 magnus is going for
maybe a close sicilian setup
and e6 we have knight to f3 and now
knight
to c6 and he does strike in the center
with d4
we have captures captures and now queen
to c7
uh we have bishop to e3 magnus just
continues development and
now a6 taking away the b5 square uh from
uh magnus's knights here uh we have
bishop to e2 and
now b5 so this has all been played
before nothing out of the ordinary here
uh we have captures on c6 queen captures
and now
e5 preparing bishop to f3 as you know
that uh black also wants the finca of
his bishop
and you're never really worried about
anything like queen captures on g2
because bishop to f3 both defends the
rook and
attacks uh black's rook here so that
just be losing for
uh for black so instead after e5 we have
bishop to b7
bishop to f3 countering this uh queen
bishop battery
and now queen c7 magnus trades on b7 we
have captures captures in queen d3
uh you could uh castle right away but
magnus goes queen to d3
he says i might be castling queen side
but i also might be casting king said in
the future so we'll see what happens
and known moves here are uh f5 and
bishop to b4 however here we have knight
to e7 by nipple
and it is already as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game
and magnus starts uh to uh well
play uh very very interestingly uh from
this point on he plays bishop to c5
now he says okay once you move the
knight i can always capture the bishop
and you lose castling privileges but you
are more than welcome to grab my pawn on
g2
and there's nothing wrong with capturing
the pawn but it's uh
it's questionable what what do you get
uh because if if you don't gain anything
and you maybe lose a little bit of time
and
your position isn't all that active and
it's not
i mean the knight will stay here the
bishop cannot be developed the rook's uh
really
not doing all that much maybe you don't
want to grab it but nepo he doesn't care
he grabs it either way he plays bishop
captures on g2 and he says okay
prove to me that this is not working for
me
so magnus just castles queen side he
adds another piece into the game which
is the rook on d1 now the rooks are
connected
uh end here queen back to c6 so napo
grabbing upon nepal now retreating with
the queen and now
can he survive this position well magnus
says nope
no you can't he plays knight to e4 he
defends his bishop on c5
and also he has uh ideas of bringing
this knight over to d6 and that'd be
if that happens that's just game over so
you have to make some room for the king
uh or uh you have to be ready to
eliminate the knight with something like
bishop captures and d6 so here we have
knight the f5
and now both the knight and the bishop
are defending the d6 square
so here bishop captures an f8 rook
captures on f8 and
now just rook h2 e1 so nicely
uh nicely centralizing the rooks and you
can't really kick away the knight from
here you don't have the g
pawn or the e pawn to maybe try and get
an outpost for your knight on d6
but that's what nipple was going for so
here we have rook to c8
you have to be a little bit careful here
if the queen moves then queen captures
and c2 will be checkmate
so magnus first goes king to b1 and now
f6 uh nipple goes after this very strong
e5 pawn and here magnus just defends it
you could however
capture and it could be could be very
interesting but
it's a rapid game you don't have all the
time in the world to calculate
but i will show it because it's just
super fun for example g
capture is now knight to c5 and i'll
look at all of these uh
squares and pawns that are attacked it's
just crazy for example
rook to f7 you had another defender we
still capture
just queen capture uh knight captured
sonny 6d captures and queen captures on
f5 now you cannot capture because uh
the e pawn is pinned and also you still
defend against checkmate as the queen is
covering the c2 square so here
uh white would just be better uh the
black king is still in the middle of the
board and it's
it's very unlikely you'll be able to
hold this in a rapid game but who knows
so instead after f6 magnus just
solidifies with f4
uh we have f captures on e5 f captures
and now
h6 by nipple taking away the g5 square
as well from
uh the knight on e4 and now rook the g1
just going uh uh putting a rook on the
semi-open
uh g-file and maybe you're you could
throw in moves like rook the g6 and so
on
so here nipple plays uh queen to d5 and
this is just a really interesting move
uh because it doesn't work
that's uh putting it plainly it doesn't
work for a spec
very specific reason so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
specific reason
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
finding this uh well i i want to say
obvious move but
obviously it's not that obvious so for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's knight to d6 with check this is
what nipple missed and
this is what magnus played almost
instantly
the problem is if the knight is captured
then you have this queen g6
check and now you just lose a queen the
knight will block of course we have
captures captures
and that's it e6 and black's entire
position just falls apart
for example we could capture here with
check king d8 we're gonna grab the other
pawn as well
king c7 something like rook here and
that's it
this is unplayable uh so instead after
knight the d6 nipple said all right i
can't
go for that i have to play king to e7
and i have to give up uh
give up an exchange here there's nothing
to be done so magnus grabs it
with check rook captures and now and
only now magnus very happily trades
queen
so queen captures pawn captures and he
grabs a pawn while he's at it so rook
captures on the e5 we have king the e6
pushing the rook back
and rook the d3 and now the situation
here is uh both players have five pawns
however magnus is up the exchange and
nipple will most likely win the e5 pawn
so here this is a liability so you want
to
get rid of it so g5 and uh you're
basically
hoping to somehow get those pawns up the
board uh with maybe some uh
a h4 h5 g4 h4 and maybe in the future
you can create a pass pawn here since
you do have a two to one advantage
on the king's side so magnus goes a4 he
wants to create some weaknesses on the
queen side and start pushing his
soon to be past pawns we have b captures
on a4 and now rook to g4 magnus goes
after these
weak pawns now we have rook to c6 and he
just
grabs the a4 pawn uh we have h5 and now
rook d the a3 we have g4
nepo just continues pushing his pawns
and now
now is the moment where you have to uh
act
where you have to act so uh feel free to
pause the video once again
and just you know think about the
position what do you play here
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
playing the move that you immediately
thought of first or yeah okay i know uh
some of you thought about b4 first
which is also fine but there is a a more
forcing move
and that is of course a rook captures on
a6 and this is just uh
the question is whether you can capture
this pawn and survive
black spawn pushing on the king side and
uh you can
for example a fun line that shows how
it's possible we're gonna capture this
pawn here
and now white will push b4 uh we have
h4 black will continue pushing on the
king side now we're gonna play b5
that's the point g3 now if
you capture the rook here we're just
going to push the pawn all the way or
even capture on h2
so here we're going to capture ones
characters captures and
now white has this rook captures on g3
and this is how
white prevails uh if this is captured
then you can capture
here and um well that's that's just it
you could go for some rook the c5 action
go after this pawn but then we defend
with rook to b3
and the game continues but it is uh
definitely the way to go however magnus
played king to c1 he thought he couldn't
capture the pawn
uh and now nepo just gains a very
valuable tempo
so here king captures on e5 now queen
rook captures on a6 and now h4 so
here comes rook captures on c6 b
captures and now
king to d1 so magnus needs to get his
king closer to those
pawns there we have h3 and now king
e2 we have g3 by nipple he played this
instantly as soon as magnus played king
to e2 and now
magnus just played king to f3 of course
you cannot capture the pawn because
there's this
very very uh hideous idea
that after h2 you're going to defend the
queening square yes we rook to a1 but
we still just bring the queen into the
game and now after rook captures we're
gonna capture here with
check king has to move and now uh or
maybe even uh here and now after knight
captures we're gonna then
uh attack the knight we're gonna win the
knight but it's basically just a a
a long draw we're going to get here with
the king
we're going to bring our king up the
board and the king will grab the pawn
and that's it
so this was possible but magnus avoids
it he plays king to f3 of course he
wants to win this game
and now g captures on h2 we have rook to
a1 now of course you have to guard the
queening square
now comes knight d for check now the c2
pawn falls king g3
knight captures on c2 in the now rook to
c1
uh we have knight to b4 now defending
the pawn here
now king captures an h2 uh we have king
to d4
we have b3 now taking away the the b5
squad
the the b4 square uh from the king but
also just preparing rook to
rook the c4 to to win the knight here so
nepo of course uh has to be
uh careful he plays c5 he defends the
knight and now king captures an h3 and
now it is very unlikely that uh
magnus will be able to do anything here
uh because
it's simply it's simply a drawn in game
so knights the c6 was played we have
rook to c4
king to d5 and now king to g2 we have
knight to e5
attacking the rook rook to c1 and now
nipple just plays
c4 and here magnus just traded
the pawn we have captures captures
captures and captures
and it was in this position that the
players drew the game by
uh by uh by insufficient material
yeah uh really uh uh a nice one uh i
i counted this as a plus one for nipple
uh as their you know prelude to the
world chess championship match because
nipple blundered
terribly here in the opening after he
played this um
after he played this move after this uh
queen to d5 idea uh he gave magnus all
that magnus needed but magnus still
wasn't able to win
so i think this will this will bother
magnus and even though nipple might be a
little bit mad that he blundered
uh the the position like this still he
blundered against the world champion and
then drew the game uh seemingly without
all that uh much much trouble so
very interesting to see how this evolves
uh but like i said i counted this as a
plus one for nipple
as we go towards their world
championship match in november in dubai
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it keep using hashtag suggestion
and suggest uh games for me to show
because there are too many of them for
me to follow
all of them uh i would like to thank
samit amin iran urban akron the pilot
william rideout and emilio carrado for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day